when I give you those you've had a great
career award I feel a little like Peter
O'Toole saying is it over when I got a
couple more in left in me but I am very
free and Toronto has gotten to be such a
prestigious
really yes it's right there with God so
many stars so many big names and come in
and enjoy the festival and bring their
movies with them and and you get to
really just basking it all because there
isn't that kind of pressure right now
for this kind of event
yeah but I gotta laughs I and it is
you're right it's it's great this is
coming see some friends and make some
new friends
now what got you so interested in in in
promoting the arts among youth because I
wanted you to talk a little bit about
your theater the BRIT in in in Florida
that you put together a while ago well I
was I was I was very big Rosie in the
seventies you still are
thank you no I
I've always felt it's always been a
mystery to me why
generous and
- it's rough it's a ruther there's a
consistent business
slap it down but you got a second month
go on and if there isn't somebody around
that gives you a couple of Atta boys and
all right and I I thought when I was in
college I always wanted a t-shirt that
had been through the war you know yeah
and shot a couple of times yeah I should
have a piece and boy 11 shot so try to
eat you then I found that I'm actually a
better teacher than I am an actor I I
really I read that's fantastic of
teaching yeah and you know you learn so
much more I'm not acting for kids and I
started
I didn't want to just have an apprentice
program because I've been an apprentice
and boy had it all you got you know
stand around dry towel yeah take their
gum or something happy work all night on
the flats and so I thought I'll have a
program where they'll be prentices but
I'm gonna put them on the stage so for
example
first play we did I had
Julius and vinegar gardenia with two
young friends second play Sally Field
and Brennan and
your game gets better automatically
right right away yeah it'll get better
yeah balls gonna hit you but yeah
anytime and I used to date Chris Evert
that was really about before you came to
gobble them I said yeah give me wrassle
or our box you know so I can redeem
myself from point something yeah I you
you find out that in teaching with the
kids they I call them kids
the sense of curiosity and
absolutely
undeniable
like it and I remember yeah their dinner
when I felt that way and I said don't
ever let that yeah don't get more
because somebody I promise you maybe
more than once but
and I know you won't find this out of
the way
somebody told me get out of the business
you go belong
and they're going to tell you that and
you know what you're gonna do you just
say
so here you are you know you've taught
you've inspired some of these kids to
follow their their heart in your dreams
I would love to know what you would say
to establish two young Hollywood right
now you know the young stars who seem to
be kind of getting in and out of trouble
I mean you were there and you know you
as you said you're huge and you still
are and you manage to get through it all
and still be who you are you're still
here it's it's changed an awful lot of
good things changed and I'm sure you're
not old enough to just see it as much as
me but I I see these freedom core that
we had as act
all the working actress especially all
knew each other and pull for each other
a real feeling
this is
like you guys earned it together yeah
yeah we are and and and there was there
was jealousy but it was a kind of fun
jealousy yeah I remember Eastwood saying
you're gonna go see this French felt
like I said what's so great about it he
says you don't have to be jealous of
that you can just appreciate it yeah
yeah yeah yeah I think that there's I
guess I would say to them
fine fine an actor
my
a mentor somebody that
and and watch him and I used to I was on
a contract Universal and I would finish
playing my silly that whatever little
part I had I would run over to inherit
the wind or shooting and
and watch Tracy
the guy
and then I would follow it to the car
and finally one day when
so then I would walk along with him I
never did true did I never have said
anything but then he started talking to
me
and then one day I said mr. Tracy
how do you what's the best secret
best thing is get don't let them catch
you
don't let them catch you act
make them think they watch candy ever
yes and I said is there anything he had
a real problem
when he came through the gates it was
King but I said is there anything you're
not good at and he said life
and I think if I say anything I say
you got to have something besides
you gotta have
kids
these are not your kids like this
right perfect example but have something
that
gives you a feeling of self-worth
you can bring a smile to their face
whether
what we do is certainly not contributing
to the good of the earth maybe and maybe
were not helping global warming but they
see us on television and they think you
know what
there my friend